but there's a lot of people who go to
basketball games who don't love
basketball there's a lot of people who
root for a team just to root for the
city or whatever but they don't love
basketball and i think in a way it's one
of the sad things because basketball
comes in so many different forms and
it's so beautiful and there's so many
different ways to do it that yeah i just
i'm always falling in love with
different players and different teams
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george robert george lopez oh my god omg
omg
support for the oh my god hi podcast is
provided in part by every plate every
plate is america's best value meal kit
while most meal kits come with a premium
price tag every plate offers delicious
dinners that won't break the bank so you
can try every plate for just
1.79 a meal
and that is up to a 104 value when you
order so go to everplate.com and enter
code omghi179
that's
omghi179
at everyplate.com
promotional support for the omg high
podcast provided in part by better help
big shout out to betterhelp
betterhelp supports your mental health
goals every step of the way and our
listeners get 10 off their first month
by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
omghi that's betterhelphelp.com
omghi for 10 off your first month
[Music]
this is very intimidating seeing a
picture of myself in the background hey
man you know what
[ __ ] try waking up looking like this for
60 years
[Laughter]
you know i found the trick you know
if you this is like the jedi old man
trick if you if you say to somebody
i'm tired of being a
[ __ ] old fat
ugly man they'll say like you're not fat
they'll leave one they'll pick the one
the one
you know i'm like
you know who's serum about you know i'm
just some stupid-ass old
unattractive man
they're not stupid
they pick one that you know it's a game
like you know
old people i guess play
um
[Music]
um
how good was george miken
he was he was a he was a solid ball
player if he if he came in today what
what what a what to what year could he
have played
like let's say like his talents
you know because you know how dudes ran
in the in the olympics like in the 30s
and 40s
how how how fast were those guys
compared to right now like how how far
could george mike's talent have taken
him
in in from minneapolis to what how would
he have done against bill russell how
would he have done it against kareem
you know what's funny he was a really
good athlete i think until he had some
injury problems with his legs yeah but
um he was
he was probably the best player in the
world before they kind of like
integrated the
the en the nba was two leagues at the
end of the 40s it was like the the the
abl and the end i'm getting this wrong
off the top my head the nbl anyway it
became two leagues yeah but he was he
was a good athlete for his size he was
like the original
6 10 250 pound dude who could actually
kind of move a little
so
so he was 16. he was i think he might
have played for a while yeah he was the
big man at 610
50.
but george don't forget that was like
legit there was no there was no height
inflation back then that was 610
barefoot he was a seven footer today
yeah
uh when i had my talk show
uh they asked me who i thought the
top five greatest players were i'm not
going to say the list but i'll tell you
what happened so i went to
let me drop some names
because oh no so anyways i'm i'm get a
call from my friend became friends with
the kennedys but ethel kennedy saw me
and wanted me to donate some things to
the rfk you know love the kennedys all
latinos had the plates we had the we had
the
the the
uh the blanket you you hung up behind
the couch
my grandmothers didn't call them 50 cent
pieces they call them don't be touching
my kennedys
they call them kennedy's and uh right
and um
if you said sir hamster hand they threw
you out get the hell out a barbecue
quinceanera wedding whatever so so
bill russell played with bill russell uh
kennebunkport golf course the country
club where jfk and all the
kennedys play whenever you see jfk as is
in the 60s you know he's there kenny
bunkport taking a swing and
you know it's funny man it's such a
iconic place even the home i went to the
house and
you see that you see the dock where they
would run you see the where they would
play football and i mean i went in the
house
you know wow crazy so i'm playing with
bill russell and for the first
six holes he doesn't say a word to me
not good morning not hey and
enjoy playing with you nothing
and then at the ninth hole he's we're
getting something to drink and he hasn't
said anything to me i'm like
what the [ __ ]
so he walks over to me no expression on
his face and he says hey man
i was born to pick with you i said
what is it he says on your talk show
you asked where you were asked who were
the top five nfl player nba players of
all time and i wouldn't make the list i
said that's right he didn't make the
list
do you remember why you said i didn't
make the list do you know why i said you
didn't make the i know but i want you to
tell me
because everybody else was 5-1
and you were seven feet tall and you had
the tight ass shorts
that nuts would come out you know
you know just you just had to stand
there and take the ball in
because if you spread your leg your
peachy wheels would fly off man i said
you loose ball that's where i think
loose ball foul came from the 60s
so so
you know so
in eras
and also he told me that he couldn't get
a cab after the game
and that
amazing man i mean it's just just
amazing that he couldn't get a cab
and they won so many times that
they started giving them plates and
silver tea sets
and a dinette set and they would ask the
wives what do you guys want this year if
you won the championship i referred your
opposition about some refrigerators this
year
but like the ring was so the ring was
was
like my high school ring in 79 was
bigger than those rings
but
you know
basketball
i mean i think you can that's why i
think you such a great guest is to tell
us
where they made it where they
transitioned to
some of the mistakes that they've made
and when it was at their when it was at
their best you know in 79 when
that game uh where were you in did you
watch that game magic and bird that
college game
no
uh because you're
i was out on the street hooking and
booking brother
all right but uh you know while you were
having a drink afterwards over there in
chinatown they didn't happen to have
a basketball game you know they were
delayed they didn't even show them live
chinatown didn't come till after i
worked hard right
i mean how how how did you know how did
basketball have where they wouldn't show
the nba finals in real time
wait did we start the show wait a second
when did that happen yeah we we segway
right into it i i can do an introduction
to all the loose ball follow that's all
in there
no i like this i like it better this way
um
i think it was a little more
let's let's go back even before like
world war ii oh basketball was a rapidly
growing sport in the us
um
probably more so than people think
coming along really really quickly
and between racial segregation
and the war that growth kind of got
derailed after the war
it picked back up and i think probably
peaked with the classic 60s guys that we
think of like bill russell you mentioned
wilt chamberlain elgin baylor jerry west
this was kind of like the first golden
age i think
and then the 70s the aba came along
and the talent split a little bit and
the aba was really exciting it had its
own thing right yep they had they had
the striped ball dr j you know the aba
got dr j which was a big deal
but you had rapid expansion from that
growth in the 60s
the nba went from like nine teams
in 1966 i think off the top of my head
to 22 teams in like five six seven years
plus the aba had eight or nine teams so
the the
talent pool got diluted the players got
spread out and then you still had kind
of from a marketing standpoint if you go
back i mean you probably lived through
more of it but if you go back just all
that ugly racial stuff marketing wise
where it wasn't it wasn't accessible to
the 78 of white americans that kind of
thing and then
in the 70s and even into the 80s
the cocaine epidemic caught some of the
players in the league
so you had you had all this stuff
happening
and by the time you get to like the mid
late 70s that's where you get oh the
finals are on tape delay
oh how how are we going to how are we
going to change the economics because i
don't think a lot of people realize that
economics by the time like bill russell
retired in 1969 or
will chamberlain retired in 1972 it was
one of the highest paying sports in the
country the average nba basketball
player played made like a million
dollars or something it's really really
well paid wow and then the 70s were a
period where you wanted to have this
growth but
there were issues there was stagnation
and that takes us to that 1979 college
championship game where bird and magic
and there have been documentaries made
about this they kind of revitalized this
new golden era of the 80s
with you know hey i can play this game a
different way i can play with pizzazz we
can bring in all the creativity the
inspirational jazz all the beauty that
makes basketball so exciting that's my
abridged version i'll stop there
no i mean i mean absolutely i mean um
you know and then one was black and one
was white even in in in 79 you know and
i think that helped yep yeah it helped
and when was from indiana and one was
from detroit i mean the last white man
in detroit left
hey he already started canada i never
followed the round ball sport because
they didn't have a lebron gonzalez or a
kareem garcia you know there was there
were no penalties if you keep throwing
that [ __ ] that same reference every time
they didn't have a skydive they didn't
have delta of martinez
okay
they've been mexicans playing just
because they didn't let you play in
dress shoes don't don't you know
or or take your kid under your arm under
the basket no kids were allowed under
the basket but but uh uh you know
mexicans have put you know hey
if if we didn't play they're the biggest
fans of of this game name a famous
basketball player mexico uh uh nahadah
that played for the dallas won a
championship
limpet loyo and the exit is on your way
up pick up some flowers for your wife
uh uh uh
you know so so so i mean listen i
i don't know channel nine and ellie
wherever you saw it but before racial
segregation before the war what made it
appealing like did everybody play and
at some point it was
i'm gonna at some point
it was you were just
it was just fun to play
before somebody had to be better than
somebody else before you they couldn't
pick gayle because you know he was up
loud hooking and booking them or
somebody seemed slower or somebody
wasn't a a a passer you know
and and it was just a good game to play
and then it started to become really
competitive and just like in little
league when your kids play and then all
of a sudden
you know that's why they took away
keeping score because kids would cry but
[ __ ] crying is part of [ __ ] losing
[ __ ]
it is man i never won a championship
baseball i lost every time i went to the
finals and those guys would rub their
trophies against their dicks and go hey
you would be like well i'll be rubbing
my championship trophy on my dick next
year we'll see and nobody got offended
and you know nobody they did it involves
we did it in balls of fury where pat pat
was like whoo and he's just like tastes
good and he took off with the trophy
because it hurts to be second place
when you really care about what you're
doing at least it hurt me
and now
kids jump rope without a rope
they play catch without a ball
and it's just you
you lose its competitive you lose your
competitiveness
of
gil you played little league right yes
okay when gil played the little league
they called it little league and then
one big one that's what they called the
league when he was in there no no just
kidding a little league a little gordita
third base
nobody ever scored but but you know
part of that was you had to try out
and you had to be good in the tryouts
even back then and then all of a sudden
the fun went went out of it
i think
because now you have kids that expect
everything given to them but
when we were growing up they didn't give
you anything and if you wanted to win
you had to work harder i think my
freshman year in school i got cut from
the team
because you know you're trying to make
the team baseball yeah and i was
catching
and last day of cuts that was the last
one they cut and the coach just told me
says sorry son
we're building our team on speed and you
can hit you're good and stick but speed
you don't have
and i didn't listen if you were a
catcher and they cut you because you
were slow
were you going backwards
did you run to third base by accident
because the catcher was always the
catcher was the spot where
they put the person where do they where
do they hide the person in basketball
that can't play
the bench usually
i think that's the answer
i mean but some guys when they come in
they would be like oh no
oh my god you know like the nba where
they'll be like all this dude's coming
in man oh my god well i that's that's an
extinct position now though that's the
mark madsen you know like you need you
need a big off the bench who gives you
energy all that kind of stuff who
doesn't
have the kind of skills that all the
players today have to have with the ball
dribbling passing shooting all that you
were you were talking about playing
catch without a ball
and man i could go on for hours about
how good of a shooter i was without a
basketball i i mean i didn't miss
occasionally but i'm talking like 90 96
97 percent
pretty good yo when they told you you
couldn't run you should have told the
you should have told the coach watch
this and went like this and then went
like that you said i already went and
got back
[ __ ] who's gonna see it
again kick up some dirt put some dirt in
your hand like this
i'm back
that's what nobody knew back then
so on the on the on the deep history
stuff i'm not i'm not super well versed
okay that's all right but but but um
well i was gonna i was gonna say one
thing about that though yep
i think
when you think about sports growing i
still think about it today because
basketball is still growing globally so
much
your overhead to play the sport is just
a ball and a hoop basically and if you
have a neighborhood that can hang a hoop
and you have a ball
you're you're good to go
and it looks to me like soccer and
basketball are going to become the two
most popular sports in the if they
aren't already technically the two most
popular sports and what's interesting to
me about that is soccer's play with your
feet where you have no dexterity and no
opposable thumbs and basketballs to
sport with your hands right
yeah that's true i think i think though
let's say
do we agree that sock
foot
is it football foot football so i don't
know what country are we in let's see if
you're gonna call it if you're if you're
a warin
and if you're a wada i think that's it's
football
and if you're
a person who speaks english it's soccer
if you have an accent it's football and
if
you're a normal person okay
uh uh uh but but you know world cup i
mean i mean man listen i mean
envision quest
the movie vision quest if anybody hasn't
seen it
oh yeah go see it it's one of the most
incredible movies
right before i started to do my specials
i would watch it because it's just
inspiring have you seen it
now you got to see it um
this guy cries if when when grant gets
back he's going to cry
he cries at the just see watch right now
he's like
so so can we you want to talk about what
what scene i'm talking about in the
kitchen
no is vision quest uh is that like a is
that like a wrestling vision quest was
matthew bodeen
okay and he was trying to move up and
wait to wrestle shoop which is the guy
who was
the beast of of wrestling up in spokane
washington
and he worked in he worked in
room service in high school
and the guy was the the
the cook was a guy who never missed the
day
and he started to train he started to
lose weight and he started to get
you know bloody noses and then he and he
he was saying hey man you gotta you
gotta eat and and he said hey uh
if i wrestle shuper you'll be there and
he's like i'll be there he goes and you
know why he says because
i was watching pele play
and what this guy could do
with the soccer ball and he goes i've
never seen it like it i wasn't there and
he kicked this ball and he made it and
he was by himself and he started crying
just at the ability that this guy had
and that
how great an athlete pele was
and to see somebody do something amazing
that he
could be at he was going to be there i
mean a very
very
an underdog movie like rocky like all
the great movies like rocky
like purple rain is underdog movie i
think uh and uh
so
but the ability to have it to put it on
the line you know to have it put on the
line and and
you know you could talk about basketball
you could talk about
i mean i mean i was growing up i i you
know my grandfather didn't play
basketball
and i grew up in san fernando and we
used to play nobody wants to play
basketball without a net you know i mean
you can i mean if you're poor but nobody
wants
to see you want to see the net swoosh
it's part of the whole
that's part of the whole thing of
basketball you know hitting the bottom
of the net
so at san fernando in the summer
we were we were playing basketball and
we said let's go let's go buy some nets
they were like 55 cents we got
two nets and then we said we put them up
and then the next day somebody stole
them overnight
the new the freshnet for those who have
never done this the fresh net is like a
sacred experience oh my god yeah and
then it was beautiful man like i mean
but this but i've you know been
fortunate enough to go to quite a bit of
nba games and the and the rotation that
they had
in the 2000s and 90s
they don't i don't see too much rotation
like i did
before man with the real shooters i saw
real shooters and the ball would be
spinning and it would just go
that just a beautiful
they
right then they spin it right i don't
know how they do it dude
when they shoot up
that's your that's your wrist flick
that's that snap of the wrist is that
ball um beautiful
and then
so i'm i'm curious i have a question for
you i get this a lot and i'm pretty
agnostic to different eras i like a lot
of basketball history i like the modern
game they all have different things i
actually really like the game today with
the exception of a few giant things that
kind of bugged me
what what's your favorite era i mean
you've seen a lot of lakers great lakers
teams what's kind of go who do you think
about today in the past
who's your favorite basketball player
rodriguez before we started this who's
your favorite uh mexican basketball
player momo rodriguez
fluffy
before we started the the podcast i was
telling grant
i've been to two basketball games
and i really didn't start what even
watching care about two basketball games
at 1700 weddings
until the uh lakers went on their when
they started winning the championship
back to back
and and i just
even at that i've just never been
interested in basketball
racial improprieties no the last five
minutes of the game are the only things
that are worth it
it hurts me
i mean we got a transition my
grandfather loved the dodgers and then
the dodgers would be losing
one to nothing in the seventh inning
with bases loaded let's go they're gonna
lose what the [ __ ] is that
so i was i would say
it's a really you know and i i'm gonna
say that you can't say
who's the greatest
basketball player of all time you can't
say that you can't say it it's eras you
have to go through eras but but ben you
know correct me if i'm wrong you know
like i'm i'm older
and i don't
appreciate the game that's being played
right now because i compare it to when i
was younger and then the young guys
don't know the predecessors some some
guys in the league even had trouble
telling each other who michael jordan
was
i mean it's just their focus is not on
the the history
of
their sport you know it's just playing
it in the now like i don't think you can
truly understand what
what a sport is unless you understand
some of the i mean you could tell you
know dodgers right sure did you ever see
sandy kofax play yes did you see her in
fact i was i was in trouble one of his
perfect games i was in trouble so my dad
took my sister to the game instead of me
and he threw a perfect game through a
perfect game yeah i was going to go to
the game and i didn't go and they had a
big fight that night against the cubs i
think you know that's like [ __ ] that
it's like missing that but but but um
you know
um
man i mean
i thought will chamberlain was
incredible i like those lakers that
didn't lose a game like they won 33
games in a row
yep those are 72. yeah i do have a
question i just heard on the news
yesterday lebron just made
uh scored so many points
and he's the second highest scorer
scoring basketball player
in history yeah who's number one what
was the number
the kareem
is over yeah you know where him
and around that and a cup of coffee
you haven't gave a nice little pick me
up in the morning
uh
you know i am i
okay let's continue talking about that
but but i would say that
i would say that
i appreciate you know
one of one of the one of the ignorant
things about sports and fans is that if
you are from los angeles you can't
appreciate
the knicks
you can't appreciate
i'm not going to say the celtics [ __ ]
them
because i'm a laker fan but but they
would say [ __ ] me so [ __ ] them and i'm
gonna say [ __ ] me too so but you but you
can't appreciate you can't appreciate
the balls if you have a shirt they'll be
like hey man i thought you were and it's
just you know
you i appreciate the game i love the
lakers i love i love the dodgers
but also like i just the ability to see
great players shouldn't
diminish your love for that person or
where they play like the knicks i love
the knicks
i think i remember watching the next
growing up i got this i got to meet
walt frazier and earl the pearl monroe
and the butcher and all i mean i met a
lot of i met john havlicek
i mean i've met incredible basketball
players and appreciated them for their
talent and i think that's what's missing
in today's game if you go you know
i if you go to a game and
they think you're a bandwagon fan if you
like if you like someone else but
there's some amazingly talented
individuals on
on in on basketball teams right now and
we shouldn't get locked into uh loving
them because
only were you only by area code or by
state
yeah
that's some extensive name dropping i i
can't compete with that
i don't know how to follow up no no i
mean listen i i no no but i mean i and i
thanked them for up you know i was happy
you know most of them were wearing their
rings
having a check had a ring on
you know and those guys uh you know they
those are you you watch those guys
playing i mean i saw sandy colfax i mean
these guys are like sandy kovacs may be
one of the nicest people i've ever met
in my life he's a true gentleman
you know tommy
was the opposite tell me sorry go tell
you to go [ __ ] yourself if you said hey
tommy told you to close the door
you know what you know just just
beautiful
i like that i like that i like that the
owner of the red erbach when they won
would light a cigar as like that's like
you might as well be rubbing the trophy
on your balls and go hey next year
yeah he would light that cigar
okay we're back and we're talking every
plate every plate is america's best
value meal kit while most meal kits that
you're familiar with come with a premium
price tag every plate offers delicious
dinners that will not break the bank so
let every plate plan shop and deliver
everything you need to cook a delicious
meal at a consistently low price you can
choose from 17 delicious weekly recipes
and then basically sit back they deliver
the ingredients they're all
pre-proportioned out and they send you
these easy to follow recipe cards all in
one kit right to your door
every place quality ingredients come
carefully packaged and pre-portioned as
is the term it helps you save money and
reduced food waste that way you're not
throwing out you know like a pound of
spinach every week because you got too
ambitious and bought it like i do
they deliver the pre proportional
ingredients and easy to follow recipes
right to your door so i'm a big fan of
this company like we support it here on
the show i have literally cooked this
food for dates before and gotten a very
impressed reaction i'm not a good cook
that's basically a comment on every
plate itself so we're very happy they're
sponsoring the podcast they're a great
product
you can try every plate for just 179 per
meal that's 1.79 cents per meal by going
to everyplate.com and entering code
omghi179
that's every plate for just 179 per meal
get started at everyplate.com and enter
code omghi
17
that's up to a 104 value with every
plate here on the omg high podcast we're
big believers in mental health mental
wellness bettering yourself and one of
our sponsors today betterhelp is just
some of the best out there at that so if
there's something that's
stopping you from achieving your goals
something interfering with your
happiness you should check out
betterhelp.com
omghi
i can personally attest to it i've been
seeing a therapist my entire adult life
i don't know how anyone gets by without
doing it a big fan we all recommend uh
mental health taking care of yourself
very important uh no matter who you are
no matter your situation so betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you can connect in a safe and
private environment it's all online it's
very convenient you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not a self-help line
it is professional counseling done
online and done securely you can send a
message to your counselor at any time
and you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions you don't have
to put on your makeup you can just do it
straight over the phone these days and
the service is available worldwide it's
more affordable than traditional offline
counseling and even still financial aid
is available uh through betterhelp they
have
licensed professionals who are
specialized in everything from
depression stress anxiety relationships
anger sleeping trauma family conflicts
lgbt matters grief self-esteem
basically if there's if you're having an
issue there's someone that they can help
you out with so anything you share is
confidential it's convenient
professional affordable testimonials
posted on their site
and in fact so many people have been
using betterhelp that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50
u.s states so i want you guys to start
living a happier life today we all the
pod do as listener you'll get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at betterhelphelp.com
omghi join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their menstrual
health and again that is better help
help as in help you help me
betterhelp.com
omghi
i actually i grew up in boston oh and
when i was when i was seven years no
don't worry you didn't offend me
all of those things this is my this is
my version of this story okay great
when i was seven years old i was out in
la visiting my uncle who lived here and
i just fell in love with it just the the
palm trees and the light and the beaches
and just absolutely fell in love with it
and uh
one night we went to toscana for dinner
and i'm i'm a little kid so after that
pasta hit
that that was it i was like
is there like a place where i can
recline and lay down actually now that i
think about this i do this now as an
adult as well after dinner i'm like do
you have a seating for me which
apparently in like in like french
laundry they have stuff like this you
can actually take a nap in the middle of
the meal anyway
i'm getting sidetracked um
i lay down at toscana right next to me
is michael cooper
and he was you know i'm like a kid in
the booth next to him he was really
friendly started interacting with me i
perked up
and
after that i was like
i'm going to need one of those laker
hats i'm going to need a 30 i'm going to
need a 32 poster on my wall
um wow i was right around the age when
bird hurt his back too so kind of like
my first introduction on the east coast
was
all these stories about the celtics
current and past from bird mikhail
parish all the way back to russell i
ended up going to robert parish's
basketball camps for years he used to
toast me in one on one which now that i
think about it why was i was like four
foot three and he's seven feet tall why
was he playing me
so much in one on one
the chief
anyway
all this is to say at some point in
there
i fell in love with the larger sport
that you're talking about and
the players the teams different systems
different coaches they've always sort of
um done it for me they've they've hit
that lit that fire in me as a fan and i
you know people like are you still a
celtics fan
i've i think i've been a fan of like 28
or 29 teams at different points and one
thing i've come to learn and i don't
know if it's bad necessarily because it
makes the industry bigger and exciting
and maybe sometimes a little toxic but
there's a lot of people who go to
basketball games who don't love
basketball there's a lot of people who
root for a team just to root for the
city or whatever but they don't love
basketball and i think in a way it's one
of the sad things because basketball
comes in so many different forms and
it's so beautiful and there's so many
different ways to do it that yeah i just
i'm always falling in love with
different players and different teams so
how did your uncle take the fact that
you were digging the the lakers and not
to sell that couldn't i mean what i said
had to be easy and it had to be soft
compared to what he told you
well my uncle had already moved to la
and i don't think cared about sports
in the slightest so he was fine um
my dad on the other hand had to be more
tolerant and he was he was pretty
tolerant but my dad now still sends me
texts i mean the celtics have been on
fire this season but i've been getting
texts for like 26 straight years even
before texting my dad was sending me
carrier pigeons about the celtics when
they won again i mean the dodgers on the
giant rivalry is nothing compared to the
lakers and the celtic rivalry
you know i didn't go to the garden but
you know the lakers that i've talked to
said it was awful
and hot and dead spots on the floor
and the leprechaun and
george george in the garden they had
seats where you couldn't see the floor
and i always i always wondered about
this later in life that like did wasn't
this normal for other arenas yes i sat
okay for game seven between the bruins
and the canadians another classic sports
rivalry and they they got in the playoff
series i want to say in like 94 off the
top of my head and me and my brother and
my dad we all got tickets for game seven
amazing game bruins one five three
couldn't hear the whole night
i'm not kidding we sat behind a giant
pole and we took turns sitting in the
one seat that you could see the ice
yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh um
uh you know i we performed the comedy
get down in boston at the at the at the
uh tc
award on tc whatever whatever it's
called now it's not called the boston
garden anymore i mean but but it's
called it's a it's a bigger place the td
i think the td garden yeah the td garden
they tore down the boston garden
uh
i mean that's just where the train i
shed a tear where the train ran acro it
ran right up to it man i mean it said it
was just like an old hospital and i said
boston garden and
go in there and i remember jack
nicholson would sit up at the top
in the 80s he'd go to the games and they
were like you're not sitting down here
[ __ ] get your ass up there and
then go look at jack up jack was at the
top of the top top like up there
and um
you know
and then going in there and seeing
the bruin championships but also going
into the arena early and seeing all the
boston celtics championships is
it's impressive man
it's painful but it's painfully
impressive
uh because in the 60s and in the 70s and
the 80s like they
they dominated man check this out girls
so they're playing game seven was it
game seven in la with the balloons on
top yeah
yeah 1969 so 1969
the lakers are playing game seven at the
forum
and the lakers
have balloons
thousands of balloons on top ready to
drop when they win
so the celtics go out there
and they're like oh [ __ ] these dudes
think they're gonna win
and they didn't win and that's a shot
that tommy heinsohn hit
it hit the back of the
of the
nellie hit it nelly nelson oh john
nelson hit the back of the rim
shot straight up
and straight down and went in
and i mean that's just it's never i've
never seen it happen again
that that goes back to the bill russell
thing with
bill russell played something like
15
winner take all games in his life and he
won all 15 of them
and
and he was he was uh he was famous for
kind of you know the motivational the
mental aspect all that stuff like like
he would go over to wilt chamberlain's
house and have dinner with him and try
to soften him up and then later on once
he retired he's like i don't need to
worry about that i've already taken care
of my business um
before that game with the balloons jack
kent cook was the owner of the team at
the time and he hung him up there
and i think it might have been our back
or one of the other players
i don't know if it would be our back
because russell was also coaching the
team he was player coach in that season
right yeah
somebody took him out there and told
them that they had balloons up in the
stands and there were some choice words
after that and he's like there's there's
no way they're winning that game and it
turned it was a very close game it
turned out to be um the celtics had a
decent little lead in the fourth quarter
and then they made a big run with wilt
chamberlain on the bench who he like
twisted his knee or something and he
didn't get along with the coach
and there was all still to this day
debate about whether he should have been
put back in they made a run with him on
the bench
nelly hit that shot they held on to win
and then russell basically retired that
was his last game retired after the game
11 championships amazing
yeah amazing and then
um
phil jackson won i don't think people
realize phil jackson won as a member of
the new york knicks
yep won a championship
and you know i think as we talk about
this um
i think a good thing to mention is
whatever sport that you love
you know
love it for you and don't hate other
people who who love other other teams
man it's like
i'm responsible i'm a bit guilty of that
but remind remind yourself
what made you a fan of of of of that
sport you know of going to dodger
stadium on
batting glove
night
and then the next day
in little league on saturday everybody
has a everybody had like a dodger
batting glove you know
and or
or helmet night you know or cap night
those things were all
great parts of of growing up in other
cities too you know and and
those are the things that inspire you to
become
either you know your friendships with
other the guys that are on your team
and you know like
things that you remember
forever that take place in this
this little court or this little you
know field that you'll remember forever
right did you ever hit one at the game a
game-winner at the at the buzzer or
i've probably hit a game-winner yeah or
um i mean just that that sense you're
talking about of
the camaraderie with with a team it can
be a unique experience i think it's
something that
people have tried to replicate
in in corporate life now right but it's
it's it's not it's not necessarily the
same thing athletics can be kind of
their own
their own thing um
i i have a random question what are you
guys drinking
oh we're drinking uh gail you want to
tell
i saw the company
uh we're drinking george lopez brewing
company beer
and he reads it all the same he reads it
all the time
like he's in court on brew
this is little mex beer
and uh it gets you in a very
philosophical mood especially after
listening to george
telling us what we should uh
we should all be
kind to one another
yes i think so it's it's really good
it's one of like four flavors that he's
got i'm like i'm i know [ __ ] fan
like it's one of my favorites so it's
really good we'll send you some do you
drink
almost never but i do i i am a big fan
of beer as a in terms of flavor so um
this is the only beer i drink i i
normally
on a daily i don't drink beer
but this is a can of that size i'm an
extremely cheap date at this point i
can't make that size doesn't matter i
mean we were here that might make that
might make take me two days to get
yeah this would this would uh be doing a
podcast um
before we lose everybody that's that
had been listening for the last year
sorry sorry no no because of me because
of me uh um
let's talk about the state of the game
as we speak now in 2022
where is it i haven't been to a game my
last game that i went to
hmm no i wasn't
um pre-pandemic right obviously it was
pre-pandemic
and
and
it's because it's not because they went
from the staples center to the
crypto.bullshit.fuckthat.com arena
but
to me that that's uh
you know we're very mexican like they'll
say that's where that's my grandma's
house even though she hadn't lived there
in 50 years
uh
the the that arena over there the crypto
kitchen my mother.org is to me will be
kobe's house
uh forever
to me i don't care how anybody else
thinks but i went to his last game i
went to a ton of games i knew one moment
i did beautiful just a wonderful
relationship to be able to see one of
the greatest players ever so many times
and i would even say i'm going to try to
go as much as i can because he's not
going to play forever
and
i was at that game that they were losing
to the mavericks by 33 points and came
back and won
is that the regular season one the
regular season one as a matter of fact
if you look up if you look it up on
youtube or wherever you'll see me
sitting right next to the mavericks
bench well all while the lakers are
starting to drain oh no kidding drain
threes yes out there that i was standing
up at that point and they those guys i'm
not sure how they got behind 33 points
but they won gill
was that the same one where kobe
outscored like the entire mavericks team
all right in the first three quarters no
that's a different game oh that's that
was years later that's a completely
different game yeah
that's the one to wear
you know who i missed the most of in
basketball in los angeles dancing barry
the dude that used to show up at the
laker game remember dancing barry i
remember dancing barry and he'd be like
in a white tux
with a purple bow tie and he would just
be going skinny little guy he was the
mascot of the the the uh
did the celtics have a mascot
the leprechaun they they technically
have uh like a lucky the leprechaun but
there wasn't a dude dressed up as there
wasn't a guy who unfortunately didn't
reach the height
that more
natural adults did and you know and he
was a little shorter
but
but they had they had something that
that started when um garnett and alan
and pierce joined up in 2008 where they
had a guy from like i want to say
american bandstand or something who they
would put up on the jumbotron his name
is gino
so it's like a 70s clip of a guy dancing
and they would only put it up in a
blowout in the fourth quarter when the
game was wrapped
and that became its own i don't know if
they still do so if you were playing and
you saw that dude up there you're like
man let's get the hell out of here
let's get out of here
uh didn't the the giants had uh don't
stop believing
in the seventh inning the guy and then
the dodgers tried to do it
and then
the giants were the first team that had
a peanut-free zone
were you if you were allergic to peanuts
you had to sit in this one section
all right let's go back to the state of
the game let's go back forward yeah well
you got to take it over or else i'm
going to take it over
no i'm curious let's talk let's talk
about it don't ask me you tell me where
where it is where we are well i'll i'll
i will definitely
dive into it as much as we want but
why do you not go to games anymore is it
is it there's no there's no dancing
berry at the end of the game no
i think that um you know after they won
in 2010 that team still had
a couple of years left and they
dismantled it the matter of fact they
even took got rid of lamar odom
without even consulting kobe like they
were tight you know guys looked out for
each other probably saw them those guys
they had a really great team
and i read an article that you know
derek fisher those guys like hey man
it's like it's like you never and that's
why he's like they're in they're in
there in 2010
drinking
and just they're a wonderful team a
great team
and um
they said we can do this for a few more
years and they dismantled that team
and i think when they dismantled that
team they dismantled a bit of
what remained of the legacy of dr bus
and what remained of
what could have been more championships
for kobe
and then to see him you know get hurt
and then to come back and then go for a
rebound and land and crack his kneecap
it's just
painful to think that
they didn't surround him with the best
players when they had the best players
and all they had to do was just you know
keep some of the guys so and then you
know lebron going to uh
to cleveland and then going to my um
to miami
and just kind of building teams around
them is not really the laker way so and
i have respect for lebron as a player
he's great
but um
to me it's
it's not
what for me as a fan would be a
traditional laker team
so you you weren't excited
i mean it sounds like it sounds like
you're thinking about it through the
prism of laker the laker experience
laker fandom
and kind of the the shift in that and it
sounds like you're not as excited about
the sort of
lebron anthony davis the the latest
iteration of the lakers i love a.d i
think a.d is great you know we saw him
play when he was with the pelicans to
have him here is great i haven't gone
talk to him a little bit tried to invite
him to my party but he was training but
but uh
it's it'll never be bad enough to make
me go to a clipper game i'll tell you
that there's a there's a ceiling there
that
i'm only going to take so much but
russell west brook and just they just
don't fit it's the same thing when they
tried to bring carl malone and gary
payton and
you know they tried to build the team
and just sometimes when there's only one
ball you know
unless you're gill there's
his and mine
four i think i think the lakers have had
at least four super teams that i can
think of they they have what i call kind
of the original super team
when
wilt was in philadelphia in 1967 1968 he
came to that 1969 team we told the story
about earlier
and that had always been jerry west and
elgin baylor's team and so everybody
just assumed well you have jerry west
you have elgin baylor they're already
really good they can barely lose you
know they lost to the celtics over and
over in the finals by just a little bit
you put wilt on the team they'll run
away with it right and i think one of
the most fascinating things about
basketball is it doesn't work like that
the pieces have to fit together so
they
in a couple years kind of figured out
ended up one of the best teams ever
years later malone payton they joined
kobe and shaq again you know they made
the finals they were a good team but
it's it's not the same thing as just
adding up it's not like baseball where
you can just create a murderer's row
lineup or pitching staff
and then um
they have
this season they tried to get one that
people thought were a super team but
even in 2013 george you kind of alluded
to it at the end of that
period the the kobe pal gasol that those
years
they brought in both dwight howard
and steve nash and that was another one
that didn't quite work so this is
actually kind of a long history i've
never thought about this before but that
franchise in particular has a long
history of bringing in all these stars
and sometimes the stars
don't gel sometimes you're just better
off having
homegrown you know you got you got magic
you got worthy
who's your guy they build around kareem
bob's your uncle you're good to go fill
in with your byron scots and your
michael coopers
when dwight when dwight howard
was
with the lakers that year
they were debating on whether to bring
him back
and adidas and the lakers reached out to
me and they said would you take part in
a dwight don't leave campaign
and you know a lot of you know andy
garcia is like do i drive to cindy
hey man you're a great player dwight
sandy garcia
don't leave buddy we love you
and of course you know mr chicano i get
a d12 on my neck you know dwight howard
12 number 12.
and uh it's because it's a big thing man
they paint it on and i just take a
picture and i'm like you know la and
then the thing and then you realize how
much kobe hates it when you're like man
cause somebody take this tattoo removal
off
as soon as i got to the court i'm like i
knew this was a bad idea uh uh but but
um
it was hard to play with kobe because he
was such he was so demanding
of his teammates but
you need you know you got to have
somebody demanding if you if you if you
want to win
you know you can't just you can't just
expect to like pat riley said just open
the door let those guys run and go hey
the last guy here
lock up you know close up
but but
i was around in the 2000s and now they
have that thing have you seen the
showtime
thing on hbo
i i have and uh
yeah go ahead i have thoughts have you
have you seen no i haven't seen it yeah
i just uh caught up last night
all right
so um
i knew i knew dr jerry buss
um
i'm going to tell you man that if john c
reilly doesn't win an emmy or
uh or doesn't get slapped at the academy
awards he's going to get cheated because
because
he's just like the dog i mean the doctor
nobody's a you know a re an actor
playing somebody and you go wow that's
but to see the doctor man was
he was a he was a beautiful person
he still had the hair that looked like
boy like a gorgeous george like a
wrestler and it was kind of curly but
then it was missing and then it was on
the side and they had a shirt open and
then his pat had the big belt buckle and
some old
time boots and he had five latinas on
each side and you're like man this is
like a this is like one of those guys
you know and there was a magic to him
when he was there
and then when he passed
it
it was gone you know that that
that that pres that chairman's room
which was man
and all of the pain george jack
the the the
all of that all of the
remember our sydney was like remember or
sitting here we don't talk about that
we don't talk about the days in the
forum those are different days
the the but
that
that kind of you know it's the
leprechaun it's like that kind of
magic that you create within that arena
disappeared
and then and then yeah go ahead sorry
well no i just i'm getting philosophical
again even though i'm not having the
beer i'm having some sort of tea that
was brought to me um right before we
started
um it's not that kind of tea george i
can't i can't
speak about history you have kids man
right you have kids right no no i don't
have kids that's why i watch basketball
all day i used to work during the day
with a guy that his wife said watch the
kids his name was john bo bogey not
boginaga
negra
and he said he goes man i'm watching
these kids man
i'm watching tv i wake up
the kids are gone the front door is open
and my wife has one kid under each arm
going what john
he fell asleep with the kids running
around the streets
he goes the wife was coming home and i
was like that looks like my kid
uh uh but yeah go ahead i'm sorry
no no the only the only thing i was
gonna say is that you're making me think
philosophically about
this idea of
the the biographical perspective of
history meaning it's told through these
specific people
and if you're dr jerry boss you can come
in and you can do your best to to
sprinkle fairy dust and build a culture
but when you're there and when you're
out of the room it's it's night and day
it's different
you know we'll see what happens time
will tell but it does seem to be
uh a different thing within the
organization since he's he's left
yeah um
i'm not going to say which
reporter told me on a morning flight how
my lakers were doing
as a dig and then he said your owner
isn't even at the games
when they're on
when they're playing at home your
owner's not even there
and i said where is he
and he said your owner watches the games
down the street from staples at the
hooters
he doesn't even he's not even in the
arena he watches the games from the
hooters
and i mean that's
the doctor was always at the games when
he could be
and jeannie too
and um
it just you know
the game now you know and you know as
guys get younger you know the the
the you know the you know gil was a
detective you know detectives don't do
the work that
gil did or or that people did or doctors
do anymore like a doctor's afraid to
give you an aspirin
you know a doctor would take care of you
when you left you felt better now you
got to go see one doctor you'll see
another guy you got to see another guy
because everybody's afraid to make
a decision or a choice or you can't go
here and you can't go there but back
then you could you could you had you
could do what any you could do whatever
you had to do to win
and that's not the case anymore
whatever happened whatever happened
between the
these good team championship team
between kobe
and shaq
uh let's ask ben
oh my goodness many many a book
have been written about that multiple
books actually
have been written about that um not a
reader without
without
going too deep into it
i think over the years we've got a lot
more perspective
and
one of the
kobe he was always demanding
he always had great work ethic he always
wanted to
come in and be the first guy in the gym
and have everybody
just
be on the same page be buttoned up and
have the same goal
shaq who has now um
you know parlayed his career as a
successful businessman and now he does
media
he
obviously had an entertaining side um
a very different perspective but also a
very big personality so you have two big
personalities two big egos two great
players uh the two of them together were
one of the greatest duos ever
and at a certain point
relatively early on probably after they
won their first championship and the
year they came back after their first
championship
kobe jumped up a level i mean he was
already really good at 20 21 years old
but when he came back he kind of entered
what i think a lot of historians would
think of as his prime like now now we're
good to go now we're a guy who's one of
the top players in the league undisputed
and
i can't remember if it was that season i
want to say it was that season it could
have been the next year shaq had like a
like a toe injury
and he didn't want to get the surgery in
the off season and he very famously said
i'm gonna get i'm gonna i got injured on
company time i'm gonna get the surgery
on company time so
there's stories like this that can go on
forever that i think a lot of people uh
who are familiar with them have heard
but the gist of it is you had this kind
of tension you had these personalities
and it was probably difficult to make it
coexist i think people under under kind
of state that they were together as it
were for
what seven eight eight seasons yeah so
can i tell you a story
i've said alleged
that after that season
when
the player in question
had a toe injury
and it was right after the season and i
was on the 101 freeway
and i got off at coldwater and in front
of me was an entirely black
excursion maybe back then
this huge car all black
and at the back
of the bumper was black and it had a
superman logo
and i was like
i wonder
so the i followed the car a little bit
going up
these guys that were in the car i don't
know who was in there alleged
maybe one of them might have been a
basketball player
but just like high schoolers were doing
they were allegedly rolling up on people
and then
seeing who was inside
and as the person got closer they they
squirted them with a fire extinguisher
oh my goodness
i saw with my own eyes
and i thought instead of getting
repaired for
whatever season
that particular player might have played
in whatever particular sport
he chose to he chose the immediacy after
winning a championship
to drive around
los angeles and squirt
civilians
with a fire extinguisher
allegedly i like i got ben thank you
yeah thank you i'm you know i'm half in
the in the can even gil was going to say
allegedly if he was awake but
uh allegedly let me let me tell you
about the state of the league today
um
but a guy saying i got hurt on company
time so i'll get i'll do it on copy time
is not the right signal to send when he
used to say my team my guys sure
sorry go ahead
okay so i think the short way to
describe
the state of the league today from from
kind of like the long perspective of
what's happened with basketball is
there's more shooting
and more
what we think of as ball skills than
ever like everybody can dribble
everybody can shoot
you have to be able to pass on the move
more than ever
these positions the old bruisers the
charles oakley's of the game
they're just that position isn't around
anymore wow
and so
on one hand the thing i love about the
game today is you've got
a lot of movement a lot of space a lot
of creativity with the x's and o's which
i talk a lot about on my channel and try
to really get people to realize like
strategically there's a ton going on
there's probably more going on wow than
we've ever had in the sport i think
those are the great things a lot of
talented players
um
the things i don't love as much that i
think probably turn off a lot of people
who grew up with 80s or 90s or 2000
stuff is
you
if you go down the court
and someone sneezes near you
it's probably a foul
and between between
the types of files that are called the
frequency of fouls
um
there's a lot of that gaming the system
that you see in sock did we decide if
we're gonna call it soccer no i can't
remember i think we're gonna call it
soccer for now and then when gets home
he'll call it football
but you but you think about soccer like
flopping trying to draw a yellow card
trying to fake something there's there
wasn't quite as much of that
back in 70s 80s 90s even
and now there's a whole contingency of
players who are literally being trained
to learn how to kind of trick the
officials into getting a foul and it's
challenging in basketball because
contact is the thing you're inherently
allowed to have a certain amount of
contact but if you're a defensive player
you can't push somebody you can't move
them off their shot you can't do that
kind of stuff and so an offensive player
can initiate the contact
and then act like they got
hit
and
there's a whole sort of uh
like cornucopia of moves that you can
use to try to trick the officials
those are the two extreme things that
have happened in the game yeah and the
big man is gone too right they're all
kind of the same height now right
that's not quite that's that's sort of
uh a slight wives tale in the sense that
the average height of the players was
slightly bigger i think it peaked in
like the mid 80s
by measured height again they actually
used to measure these guys barefoot and
then at some point they switched to
inflating with their shoes right so the
players the players have remained kind
of similar size what's happened with the
big men is
you don't go in the post anymore
and you have to have skills to play
outside you have to be able to shoot you
have to be able to dribble
you take a guy
like the jayson tatum was a star for the
celtics he's about he's a big guy he's
about six eight a guy like that might
have been someone who played more in the
post and you might have thought of him
as one of the big men back in the day
and now he can play on the perimeter he
could you think of him as he can play
either forward is he a wing he runs a
lot of the offense wow so
you fill up the floor with more of these
players and you have more
interchangeable parts and that's another
thing that makes it really dynamic
strategically because on defense you
have a ton of switching and you can play
different roles and on offense you need
to be able to play those roles so i
think in many ways this is the most
exciting part of the game but especially
aesthetically you lose you lose some of
the mid-range stuff you used to have you
lose some of the post-up stuff you used
to have and you certainly don't have the
same like
quirkiness right you used to have out
there it's gonna be hard to have a
dennis rodman in today's game even i
think in the time of steph curry
starting to where we are now the game's
changed yeah yep it's this is this is an
amazing thing in the sense that
we had all that you know i talked about
pre-war and world war ii and the the
game exploded in the 60s and a lot of
sports and industries do that and then
it kind of it looked like it had matured
and all of a sudden in the last decade
there's like this explosion this boom
that in and of itself is pretty
fascinating and pretty rare yeah and a
lot of it had to do with realizing this
basic mathematical factoid which still
blows some people's mind which is that
the three-point shot is worth
50 percent more than the two-point shot
so
teams were not like taking advantage of
shooting the threes and as long as it
was there it was just this low-hanging
fruit waiting to be used absolutely as
little as i know about the game
i
i
look at it and i see it as
before
you had the nba there was a bunch of
athletes they were good they had the
post-up man with the center
and you had the harlem globetrotters
they were there for entertainment
today it's more of a modern
entertainment for everybody since you
don't have the
everybody does everything and they move
around
just as much as the globetrotters did
yesteryear
it's funny you mentioned them because
they were actually a cutting edge team
way way way back when
and
a lot of the old teams
played almost similarly to the way teams
i'm talking really old like 60 70 80
years
played more like today in terms of
moving and not having a guy in the post
that's what i see
yeah that's right
and so what you've what you've got what
you've ended up happening have what
you've had end up happen
is
all of the talent all of the shooting
all the ball skills all the crossovers
all the fadeaways all this stuff that
has been growing for 30 or 40 or 50
years
now you kind of bring in these old hey
don't go to the post
go to the free throw line and let people
run around you and if you're not careful
you're going to get a three-pointer are
you going to get a back cut for a layup
and in many ways it's created some of
the most beautiful basketball we've had
in the in the hardcore basketball
circles the 2014 spurs who were kind of
on the beginning of this movement
they're they're just their nickname is
the beautiful game spurs that's just
what they're thought of this sort of
parallel coming from sauk you know the
beautiful game of soccer all the flow
and the movement and the things that
happen away from the ball um
yeah that's sort of that's sort of my
summary about the state of the game now
i i what do you guys think george is
texting about it no i always get
fascinating i was uh very good friends
with mr meadowlark lemon meadowlark
lemon oh wow and he was a genuinely
beautiful beautiful person and a loving
guy
and
you know i never thought that the kid
who you could look it up george in
meadowlark
that the kid who tried to make a harlem
globetrotters jersey
out of
a t-shirt after watching them on abc on
whitewater sports would become friends
with
meadowlark lemon and he signed a
basketball for me
and signed a jersey for me and
he we played golf together
and he was awesome man i mean one of
those guys that is just
beyond
what you imagine a person could be just
a beautiful
you know and we we lost them a few years
ago but
you know i said hey man what about that
you know
right there that's one right there baby
i can hold on hold on you can see maybe
start crying yeah that's done together
man look at that picture man come on man
where's abe sapps abe saperstein he's
gone
man and with all the money with all the
with all the money abe sepperstein
and then what there's there another team
in harlem too the one that was like
knock up of the the wrens the wrens in
like yeah the ram but i think that
i think they were the best team i think
they were considered the best team and
again you get into this segregation
stuff where there was a period where the
white teams is like in the 30s or
whatever we're going around barnstorming
and coming together and
forming these little clubs and saying
we're the best team and then you'd get
like a harlem rens that would come in
and
you know as as were the case in many
sports in the 20th century
change that idea quickly man that's it's
you know it's funny because i'm i i like
uh
i like old buildings you know i remember
trying to get me into jail
so i looked up where they played in uh
in harlem and i haven't been back to new
york but i think some of the stuff is
still
like the outside of it the facade is
still there so i would think about going
and seeing that i don't know sure as a
kid i was if i was just kind of
enthralled by like old buildings
and old stadiums you know
and things like that and uh
you know when i
first started to go on the road i drove
atlanta in philadelphia and the spectrum
was still up there and rfk stadium was
there and jfk stadium and i mean rfk's i
think in the jfk there was a jfk in in
philadelphia and uh
you know before they start to knock down
make all new places but um
uh dr j as well too i've met dr jane you
know any you know because of golf you
know golf you know you meet great people
golfing uh i didn't mean guild golfing
but i mean i sold oranges right outside
the golf course
he did and he would collect the golf
ball and sell them back to us but you
know and golf is what what gave me the
ability to meet
like dr j and be friends with dr j
showed me his feet one night and at uh
jeffrey osborne's
man this dude it's like he wore heels
and played
like he said his wife was like no no no
don't show him he goes i want you to see
what the shoes are now versus what and i
mean we're talking like
like when your wife wears heels and
she's like oh and i mean just
crossed over
but they those shoes were not
i mean i said duck i mean imagine how
high you jumped with those converse that
bird had him
i think bernard king had him
and magic had him and jay had him like
the red the converse uh
they all had their own shoe four guys
and the the the magic shoe was was gold
and larry's was green
and doctors was red and then bernard's
was like blue i think and uh those were
the shoes that everybody wanted i
couldn't afford them but
you know what i mean i'm saying like oh
yeah oh yeah
you know that kind of that kind of and i
mean and then and then you go to this
year where
during this during the slam duck contest
kareem gets up
and grabs his jacket
after watching these guys do the snap
done cause he's like i'm out i can't
watch this i'm out of here that that
never happened there was no uh all-star
saturday night this this year you are um
i think it's the beer or something maybe
whatever you want
something is making you think of this
what did he walk out of then what did he
walk out of
oh i i walked out whatever yeah that was
i think that was our least memorable at
least for me i i love the all-star
saturday night where they all get
together and they do the three-point
contest in the dunk contest and
and uh
it it has had finer moments than this
seasons yeah so you know uh if you look
it up i did i hosted and then i did not
want to do that but it was turned out to
be a great thing they they wanted to
roast kareem
uh before it doesn't sound like a good
idea
you would think
i have a kareem story oh tell me tell me
yours and i'll tell you my i got a lot
of them
so i'm i'm uh
interning with the la times in 2009 i'm
covering the lakers
i'm in the press room i can tell you at
that time
andrew bynum a lot who was a lakers
center at the time very young
and so he would he would before the
games he would work him out on the floor
and then the press room is also kind of
like in the bowels of the staples center
underneath with the locker rooms and
everything you you interact with players
coaches crossing paths
and i'm in the press room
i turn around to go probably to go out
to the floor
and all of a sudden
i get like stepped up like my feet get
like stepped on and i hit like a belly
button
right
and i'm like what the hell and i look up
and again go back to that thing with
shoes like kareem was like seven two
barefoot like he is insanely tall and i
look up and i keep looking up and i
probably hurt my neck a little bit and i
see kareem and i'm like i'm like oh crap
kareem abdul-jabbar just stepped on me
and
he just kind of like discarded me and
moved along and he's and that was that
was it
and uh
that was that was the time i got stepped
on by kareem abdul-jabbar
and what do you think that came that i
mean i i you know
you know i don't want to say you know i
don't want to keep dropping names but
um
his father was a what they call those
dudes like it was a task master you know
oh yeah was your dad tough on you was he
a taskmaster or was it he was a it was a
good dude that was cool right he never
told me what to do he gave me hints
let me make my own decisions always give
me a hint dude you know maybe it's time
to do something like this
but also but also
you know
much like my grandmother or kareem's
father
in new york or gayle's father
they never told you that they loved you
sure and that
is like
it's almost like having a ringing in
your ear like it never goes away like
whatever that causes in a kid
it it affected kareem when we had dinner
we were talking about that
he was a tough dude
and
tougher than he than he needed to be on
kareem and you know gill's dad
get went to vietnam and came back which
is unbelie thank you for your service as
well but i mean to me the idea of
going to vietnam and then coming back
when unfortunately so many people didn't
come back and then
you know
his dad told him he was proud of him and
it just it destroys you even today right
yeah it's just i i always wanted him to
say i love you he did i know he did
but it was just a cultural difference
and
and and that's and you know my
grandmother told me
and it's like
you you know to have to say i know they
did
you would rather have heard it you know
i think it would have gone a long way
with kareem
and his relationship with the press and
his relationship with the fans and he's
not a bad [ __ ] he's a great guy he
loves music
and then his house burned down he was
they were in salt lake his house burned
down and he went to go play in salt lake
in the next game and he was a big
collector of jazz music
uh and they held up
warped jazz records like hey these are
the ones that burn in your house i mean
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] man
i mean that's been that's pretty bad huh
that's coal man yeah yeah yeah that's
way before they
way before now they bang those balloons
together but they're holding up
warped
records man
yeah i
i even think
i mean
god especially since the pandemic i
can't remember what i had for breakfast
but i think
his dad started that collection right it
was it was some he had this jazz
collection yes he absolutely cherished i
think his dad might have played as well
too
it connected back to his dad somehow i
love i love how we've we've gone from
like basketball history into our
father's not telling us that they hey
man they love us
you know i didn't have a father
uh he took off and then i tell my
daughter
i mean i don't but i tell her no i mean
no my daughter and i have uh we did a
show for nbc just last week and uh
it's pretty amazing when you tell you i
can't imagine that it's that tough
to tell your kid that is your kid that
you love them
or that you're proud of them
uh and we went years that we didn't talk
but don't give up if anybody's out there
and you're not talking to your parent or
your your child like don't give up stay
in there because they come back you know
our city will help me through very
difficult time but
i think in in kareem
and in that
he still has it even to this day
if you see him
he looks like he doesn't want to be
bothered
you know and i mean i saw him get
i saw
the wonderful parts of them and then the
sky hook was indefensible
and then as people get old i remember
that you know that sent in the clowns
you know i remember they did the sin and
the clowns thing with joe namath one
time
and
when he couldn't move anymore
and it's just that song is heartbreaking
man
and then when kareem would go do the
skyhook and it started to clank and it
started to miss
when before they would go in
is you start to see
the evolution of the game change
from like kareem to
you know
magic to jordan to kobe and shaq to
you know where we to lebron and and you
know it's a like a daisy chain of of
things that
that happened you you know you know i'm
glad that you said that the game
that you think the game is better
uh now i mean it's good because you know
it's almost like crime like i don't
check the crime rate so you're telling
me that
crime is down is good you know if you
say to me man hey george the game is
probably the best players that they've
ever had right now would say hey man
that that's that's that's amazing let me
ask you something back in the day you
know you talk about
excuse me 69 70. oh
did they have
as many
stars
when i say star spike lee's
george lopez jack nicholson
you know did they have many stars there
was a a lady
a female actress
nice looking lady used to be big-time
lakers diane carroll diane carroll sat
next to her she was she was there all
the time she was there all the time yes
now did they have that back in the day
back then
like they do
today
the celtics did not
the knicks did
the lakers i believe because of
hollywood started it
and in the forum
arsenio
and i mean when magic came and changed
the whole
town the city the league
and they won their champ they won the
championship the first year
and then matt kareem twisted his ankle
didn't make the flight to philadelphia
and and magic played all five positions
as a rookie
and and won the championship
and the first game that magic and kareem
played together at the san diego arena i
put 18 000 people in there in 2009 and
on that floor
is where kareem hit the skyhook the very
first game magic first game and magic
ran over and hugged them
with his
biggest smile and his eyes closed
and kareem is like hey man
we got 81 more games one game like
the first game and it just
was part of what i'm trying to talk
about like
letting the joy happen to you man and
not be a you know somebody said a kill
joy not be a kill joy
you know not be we have a lot of people
killing joy right now
that i mean
preach yeah that that to me
is probably the thing i find myself most
attracted to over the years in the game
and on the floor i think it's one of the
reasons why it's so fun to watch steph
curry run around for 40 minutes being
chased by these bigger guys
because
as an individual or as a team
if you can play
magic habits i mean that's why i fell in
love with magic as a kid so many other
players have had it it transcends sports
in a way i think if you can play with
that passion that energy that positivity
it's like what what else are we doing
sometimes we're out there playing a kids
sport
and it's fun and it's competitive and we
love it and all this stuff going on but
if it's negative and you're a downer and
all that
for me it loses
it loses the fun
yeah okay so i think where do you what
city do you live in
i'm about an hour
south of l.a
okay uh
you
me
i'll get you guys different seats
you and aaron
you know
you guys come off the bench
[Laughter]
before the season is over
i'm taking you
and you you might have to sit on the
edge
to a laker game and we are going to sit
courtside and we're going to go do it
like we did it back
in 2010
2009
2000 we're going to go
okay all five we've done this today
we've we've revitalized this today i'm
taking you guys
and i i want you to explain to me
i want you to sh i wanna i wanna watch
the game with somebody who knows it's
good
versus sitting here with gil
exactly
all right
hey i admit just don't slap me
no no no but it's a beautiful i want you
to see it up close oh i have hey when
you go when i used to go to titty bars i
never sat in the back i sat up in the
front
i mean not teddy but gentlemen although
i never saw any gentlemen in there but
walton the only time i ever sat on the
floor was in a clippers game
and i i never really was amazing walton
i i never realized he had such big hands
big feet and so intense when he moved
around
focused you know it was most [ __ ]
feet were like potato chips too if you
turn the wrong way
they crack
too soon george it's too soon so so
he's still alive though isn't he
no i mean the injuries it's oh he got
hurt man that guy brutal yeah oh dude i
mean he played with the portland
trailblaze he won a championship he ran
off
grateful dead with the shirt off just
like this caveman with this big red
beard he's great i mean i love him he
was at kareem's roast
but he had brittle brittle just his feet
right just yeah yeah it was it was
structurally just the bottom just from
the bottom up must have played in so
much pain but with the celtics
[ __ ] man they were good and he was good
and and i played
little league the first year
in this with darren day
and darren day was on the boston celtics
the kid that was on my his dad was the
coach
his dad was the assistant coach
and darren
d-a-y-e who lives in vegas i think his
pop is still alive
won a championship with the boston
celtics the kid that was in my little
league first team ever i think he was
number 12.
that's amazing i think he was on that 86
team he was one of the greatest teams
ever but i will 25. i will say this i
will say this to anybody who still is
somehow listening to us um
i think it's a good show i like it it's
one of my favorites
if uh if you've never been to a
basketball game and sat courtside sad
favorites on the floor
it is one of the most incredible i try
to everybody who's kind of casual fan
not a fan i try to get them to do this
once in their life because there's
nothing like it because part of
athletics is this like
amazement that other people can do these
things with their bodies but when you
see basketball players it's like there
are different species because we have
plucked from the planet this talent pool
of people who can move and run and jump
and explode like this and they're all
the average guy out there is like six
seven two hundred and thirty pounds and
when you're
five feet away from it
you kind of get this sensory experience
that transcends tv you can't get it it
just is insane i have another question
for you here it goes
so
the pickings for professional basketball
players
it's even smaller than baseball players
you know football players there's more
of them so the numbers get smaller so by
the time you get to that level you're
playing college ball
and it looks like you're getting ready
to go to
pros you got a shot at it
do they start making you a prima donna
before you ever get there and that's
part of what's going on
today where before peop basketball
players were there for the sport the
love of the sport
now it's
their their preview that's all in love
with the money
i i think this is a cultural challenge
uh both within
basketball because the talent pool's so
huge now that you're right i think it
starts earlier i think by the time most
great basketball players or even
professional basketball players are 15
16 17 years old
their experience in life is going to be
skewed compared to just the average joe
sure who doesn't have people following
him around doesn't have people
whispering in their ear trying to
influence them
in some schools doesn't have you know
favors being done academically and
things like that it becomes it becomes a
different experience and then i think
you add that into just
the general
culture that we we live in which i mean
looking at we don't have time to get
into that
today but i mean i think i think they go
together in sort of
it being a different experience and and
a lot of those athletes having a
different mindset and of course having
more money
yeah than ever it's different of course
than what it was 40 years ago some still
care i'm going to tell you guys a story
here so in 2078
the lakers beat the uh orlando magic in
the nba finals night 2009. that was the
year i covered that 2009.
nine yep okay so it was
okay that's right so they lost to the
celtics
remember that
they blew some early leads in the first
two games and they lost
and the next year
they beat the magic
and then aeg who owned staples
and they were my promoters came up to me
and said
the lakers because you go to so many
games and we know you're such a huge fan
you can look up my championship ring
there as well on 2000 when they beat the
second celtics the second ten and ten
so
they say to me we want to gift you and
it had to be approved by the nba
a laker championship ring
with
them beating the orlando
magic and i said
hey as much as i appreciate it
i'm gonna
i'm gonna say no because i don't want a
laker ring
when they beat the magic i want a laker
ring if they beat the celtics so i'll
wait
and they'll say you'll wait for what and
i said i'm going to pass on this ring
and i'm going to wait to see if next
year
they play the celtics and if they beat
the celtics that's the ring that i want
and they said well
there's no way to know and i said well
the celtics are still good and the
lakers are still good i'm gonna take my
chances mr manifest destiny sitting here
and they did win
and i went to the seventh game and they
were horrible in the first half
and the laker owner was sitting next to
me i had two seats my i took and i was
getting kind of almost divorced kind of
and i took her i'm not sure why
i didn't want her back but okay
uh so there we are sitting
and we're sitting next to
i'm sitting next to the laker owner and
he goes hey george take a look at this
and it's a championship ring from the
year that they beat him and it's got a
[ __ ] shamrock on it with these green
diamonds and
it's [ __ ] i mean
it's it's just the most incredible thing
i've ever seen and it's [ __ ] boston
celtics with diamonds and a green
four-leaf clover and the leprechaun and
it's just mad you're just like and he
goes then the other one's gonna go right
here
and i said this dude right here man this
guy's killing me man so you got you this
came true you got this i told ann
and can you sit next to this dude
because this [ __ ] is just
wearing me out and he's like shoot it
ron shoot it you know metal world peace
shoot it
awful they were awful
and and there's a picture of me
courtside like
like with my hands and like you know
because i'm like man game seven man
we're gonna lose
and then i just they start to pick it up
i just want to understand this
you in
2009 you were like i'm gonna manifest
the lakers beating the celtics and they
literally did this in the next season
you go home at night after that and you
think did i like waste my superpowers
did i should i have used this for
another wish i'm still using them i'll
fill you in on some of them before we go
but but okay but but it's game seven
and you can feel the tension and the
lakers of fans are like man we're gonna
[ __ ] lose to the lakers game seven in
la again
and then it just
it starts to change kobe had a bad half
and then the guys start to pick it up
lamar
and derek
and he starts to get a little bit closer
and then it gets close to the end and
the lakers are shooting their free
throws and if they hadn't made
almost all their free throws they would
have lost
so the owner of the celtics and they're
looking at each other like [ __ ] this is
just going to go down to the wire
and then
ron artest is at that three-point line
and the whole arena's like
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
and he shoots it and he makes it
and he goes like this
and he runs off and
it's hard not to cry to to and and
when they won i mean the place goes
crazy when that ball was loose at the
end and kobe's running toward the ball
and he puts his fists up he's running
toward towards where i'm sitting he ran
to get the ball
he's like running at me
and i knew on my talk show then so he
won the mvp ran over to the desk
and the confetti is coming down and he's
going like this
he's going
you know five
and he won the mvp they won the
championship trophy and then they
presented to him and
he said on the on my talk show he said i
stood there
holding the trophy
and the mvp trophy and i'm looking at
staples and i look and of all the people
that are there
i see one dude
just that doesn't stop
going like this
and that was me
everybody else had kind of calmed down
and i [ __ ] couldn't believe it man
and i just could not stop jumping up and
down shoulder you want to show the
picture i've been trying to find it i've
been trying to find it
you couldn't find it
no not not of the ring
that uh
pal gasol also had 18 rebounds he had a
wonderful game
yes i'm sorry
yeah huge part of that and then the
other thing about that
is the post game press conference with
with ron artest who is i think now
officially something like metalwork meta
no he changed it again it's um it's meta
our test or meta meta sandiford our test
but matters
meta g sanford
um
his press conference after that was one
of the
one of the all-time press conferences he
was very special man what about yes
very progressive a very progressive
health con uh press conference in
retrospect on mental health audrey talks
a lot about his mental health struggles
and thanks his therapist which was even
in 2010 still kind of a new um pseudo
taboo thing in sports
you're exact you're exactly you're
you're very correct and as a matter of
fact
we did a fundraiser
at the house of blues and he sold his
championship ring
in order to fund uh something that he
was working on
with mental health
and like people could uh
try to raise money for it and he sold he
sold
the
one championship ring that he won
oh let me get a good picture of it but i
mean
yeah we we manifested the the destiny of
that
of that win
pretty wild man pretty crazy and then he
here's one of uh
i don't think you can see this when kobe
and
when shaq came back to play
i want to cover this because these guys
will be like
because last time they said we could see
we could see your
code
so
you can see that right
oh that's crystal clear yeah
no you can't see
but look behind shaq is it's me with my
fist up like
kick his ass
you see that that's awesome
if i'm if i'm holding hey if i'm keeping
you up gil
you know just let me know man
if i'm keeping you up you're not giving
me you're keep me entertained uh so i
mean
to be a kid and not go to a game and to
be an adult and be able to go
is one of my my the things i'm most
appreciative of
you know because
they're on channel nine and then they're
in front of you
that's how i see it it it's different
yeah it's it's a different experience
so so
can we can we
can we do a uh recap
after we all go to the game
yeah
yeah
like post are we are we gonna start the
podcast now
yeah will you introduce our guest
so at the at the all-star game in uh
2010
at the end of the game the ball was
loose
and kobe went to go get it and i stood
up and put my hand out and that's us
giving like a low two
that's awesome and then vanessa bryant
walked over to me and i said uh so
is he going to play in the second half
and he
she said
no not much i said why because he
doesn't think it's right that
since it's his home arena that he wins
the
mvp in his home arena
and i said what that's a [ __ ] right
there
and she said go talk to him
so i
wandered across the court
and i said hey cope and he was warming
up and he looked over he goes yeah and i
said v said that you're not going to
play in the second half and he said
you know i don't know
and i said
i i could have said
do not let anyone
walk out of this arena with that mvp
trophy
unless it has your name on it and he
laughed at me and he said okay
like i don't think he did it for me but
he laughed and he said oh okay that's
like saying babe ruth hey babe hit a
home run for me okay he's like oh okay
kid i'll do it but
you know
it was magic man it was magic
again when he was in those times you
know
to me
and my daughter like we went every
christmas
we went every christmas
and uh
for a lot of those years the green
devils would come into town
they played a lot of christmas games
against the celtics
hated them
but appreciated them they were fun they
were really good man big baby remember a
big baby
oh yeah awesome teams man awesome and
they wins
do the green devils man
and they went added they went at it they
played ball like right now like a
follows the fall these dudes
that blow the whistle go man you're
bleeding you need to go from where and
the other like don't touch your blood
like oh that guy would go right there oh
and then stop the game and
go back in
and i mean
just you know it's beautiful man that's
almost sad
it's beautiful will you introduce our
guest today
uh yeah we have ben taylor from thinking
basketball
i think fittingly because we talked
about basketball otherwise i could have
gone with just a disembodied head in the
monitor
in the back philosopher of life yeah
but you know
i think um
in whatever anybody uh um aspires to do
or enjoys
i think you should do it while you can
enjoy it because it life goes by very
fast you know um i lost a friend of mine
that i grew up with the first one i ever
had
and
we were driving on the 405 freeway one
morning
and we see a stutz bearcat
a stutz bearcat is a car you see that
thing
[ __ ] long
with the spare tire in the back and like
that
a stutz bearcat
and it's going
south in the morning so wherever he's
from he had to spend the night
somewhere and now he's making his way
back home
and as we get alongside of it
it's wilt chamberlain driving
with the goatee
and the devil the devil goatee
right the devil the mustache and then
the devil goatee
and we're honking bam
he won't look over bad
and he looks over
we roll the windows down we're like well
and he he went like this to us
can't drive it you want like this
dropping the hang loose
and that
thank you ben for being on the show man
that's
that was awesome
appreciate it jordan that was fun thanks
for thanks for having me we're going to
the game so we'll figure it out schedule
wise
gail you'll sit in joel silver's seat
because
uh and and you're right and then gil
will see firsthand
how wonderful it is to see him i will if
i i hope we get the opportunity hope you
can see person hopes
sit there floor side with you
um
yeah it's called courtside but anyways
uh ben you want to tell the people where
to find you any anything you're
promoting anything right now i'll find
you floor side big thinking basketball
youtube channel like i'm i'm the worst
at plugging my own stuff people ask me
what i do and i'm not worse than i am we
talked for an hour and a half i never
said your name
talk about uh talk about basketball i'm
thinking basketball youtube channel
and uh patreon.com thinking basketball
is kind of my
my home base of additional content i got
a podcast and i just spent a ton of time
but but but is uh do people use your
information uh against the spread
they can yeah
yeah
there's a there's a there's a there's a
gambling contingent that has been known
to ask me questions and follow me from
time to time
it's a lot of it's a lot of what we
talked about earlier just trying to
look at the game in a way that isn't
obvious per se or something that you
might not see
whether you're at the bar or watching on
espn or channel nine or whatever trying
to get into the strategy uh the real
deep stuff of what you know sort of
makes players excel and the non-obvious
stuff like defense passing coaching
things like that yeah and the occasional
pop culture reference and what i've
enjoyed today the most is i get flamed a
lot by the younger crowd online for
making a like a like a seinfeld
reference
and today we've just blown right pat
we've gone to the early 80s to 70. i
think we had a 60s reference in there
clark gable probably showed up at some
point today
yeah i feel pretty hip actually well
man well
listen uh when we go to the game
we're going to put some money down on it
you won't because you can't bet on but
but gil and i will
all right
and with our and with our winnings we'll
go to the hooters and celebrate with
your laker owner
all right guys i appreciate it alright
brother thank you man thank you so much
ben thank you thank you so much we'll
see it we'll see you soon i'll work it
out
okay gail yes sir i want you to open
this present
and i think when you see it you'll know
who it's for
i'm gonna love you
like nobody loves you
we can't sing songs can we yeah of
course you can come rain or come shine
guess who that's for
that is for your
wife thomas
and it is signed by mr tommy lasorda we
have a uh
it's an autographed
it's an autographed dodger jacket for my
wife it is memorabilia it is authentic
to the day
she just had her
she just had a big birthday i won't say
which one she'll do
uh
this week but you take that home and
that's for me and thank you or you can
say it from you [ __ ] it down but she
won't know i don't know hard is here
but yeah i think thank you my
grandfather was a huge fan
my grandma's a huge fan
and i like that you guys are huge fans
because that's it's part of being here
when the dodgers when
i mean look at that look at this look at
that stitching man that's beautiful
that's
you know and in my family
these jackets they were expensive
and so
in the family i had uh there were seven
kids
and my mom and my dad so what we did
every birthday
we'd all pitch in we'd buy
your birthday would buy her a jacket oh
my gosh buy them a jacket until all of
us have the same jackets
and uh that's beautiful that's great
my my mother-in-law
my swag that when she died
she was such a big fan by the end she
had uh
we buried her her clothing with dodger
stuff
and the priest that uh did the service
said i wish i would have known he was
also a chaplain for the dodgers it was
catholic priests there you go and he
says how to war my
dodger uh
investments whatever they do no no
accidents yeah so i think she'll enjoy
that huh oh i know she will
she'll be very happy thank you very
welcome
my heart and thank you
any dodger fan of
anywhere is a friend of mine
except graham
it was all good
yeah we found that and we got it sent to
us
that's awesome
was he dead when he signed it or he
signed him before he died uh on the way
to the hospital he said
hey tommy was a good dude i got a lot
well i know everybody but tommy was
she's got a picture of spring training a
few years ago
we've got a picture where he's actually
autographing her jersey yeah for spring
training he was he was you know mad what
they said cantankerous
i walked into him he was the guy that
the guy that broke me in homicide don
garcia my dear friend
uh
his wife bought him tickets as a as a
gift
oh yeah
that's great
his wife bought him tickets
for uh that's awesome a dinner with
tommy lasorda as a gift
and she says hey kill you want to take
him because you know you like that [ __ ]
i don't
so i took him to dodger stadium there
hadn't been maybe 40 people there
maximum
for the dinner
and people are standing in line to go
ahead and be with yeah meet tommy and i
i got don by this time my my partner
losing his eyesight
so i said don sit down i'll be right
back i'm gonna go talk to tommy so i
went up got in line i went up to tommy
and i said good evening mr lasorda mr
lister i didn't call him tommy mr
lasorda
i said my name's gil creo and it's an
honor and a pleasure to meet you
i said
when you're done here
greeting people
i said you see that guy sitting over
there all by himself that's the guy that
broke me in the sheriff's homicide
in 1981 that's my partner
i said he doesn't come up here right now
because he's having sight problems he
didn't want to bump into everything
i said so when you get a chance maybe
you could
come on over
and he says hell let's get over right
now
i don't need these people anymore got up
right there with people in line
when he says who's sitting here he says
nobody says do you mind if i join your
table
sat right there and joined us at the
table
it's amazing and told us some
stories that had me rolling no you have
to rewrap this maguire
mcguire
they talked that was the year that they
didn't have anybody
they didn't have anybody for the uh
they didn't have anybody nominated for
uh the hall of fame
it has paper on there and put on paper
on top of it
uh you might just put that paper
they asked them hey
how about uh
you know
what do you think about
nobody nominated for the hall of fame
he says well they use all these [ __ ]
drugs
he says that's why nobody says we got
this [ __ ] guy maguire remember he was
all [ __ ] tough and bad when he was
playing st louis all puff-armed he says
now he's we just got him as the hitting
coach for the daughters
he says look at him now
he says he's so [ __ ] skinny i could
kick his ass
you